[Music]
president donald trump continues to
question the integrity of the november
election
and he is urging supporters to monitor
the polls now election day is just 28
days away and early voting starts in 11
days the i-team's vanessa murphy has
more on a call to action from president
trump and also what the rules are
vanessa
we're outside boulevard mall and this
will be an early voting end
election day location and after
president trump
urged his supporters to come to the
polls to watch carefully
attorney general aaron ford and election
officials are warning about voter
intimidation
individuals at the polling place that
may try to prevent voters from
exercising their civil rights
that's a federal and state crime and we
will be watching for that
wayne thorley is the deputy secretary of
state for elections in nevada
despite election officials like thorley
saying voter fraud is not
widespread president donald trump
continues to say ballots may be
manipulated
he made this call to action at the first
presidential debate
i'm urging my supporters to go into the
polls
and watch very carefully because that's
what has to happen i am urging them to
do it
voters can observe the process when a
person is an observer they have to
follow certain guidelines that are set
out in law
we they are not active participants in
the voting process
they are passive observers if they
notice a problem they can contact an
election official
at the polling location clark county
registrar joe gloria says contacting his
office is also an option
for concerns about both voter fraud and
voter intimidation
put your complaint directly into our
office and we'll log that
and we would immediately send out an
admin rover if they're willing to stay
long enough for that admin rover to
arrive on scene
and address their concern if they felt
it wasn't being dealt with
and concerned voters and poll watchers
can contact the clark county registrar's
office
at 702-4555 vote and as we've been
reporting due to kovitt 19
there are several options to vote this
year voters can mail in their ballots
they can drop off their ballots at
locations like this one
or they can also vote in person
reporting live vanessa murphy
8 news now